this snack bar looks just like any other
in Berlin or cologne but it's in central
Warsaw Vorst kiosk as it's known
specializes in German sausages and it's
a hit
my buddy cut this mug it has a fine
flavor and it's very delicately spiced
liking that I'm perfectly grilled to
taste really good I've never been to
Germany but these seem like the real
thing but I'm not divisive it tastes
great after work I have won almost every
day I really like stuff it's like you
bust a guess the paper
wherever German expats live you'll find
German sausage normally but the man
behind this sausage bar is polish
Bernard was L used to be in advertising
he developed a taste for the meaty
German treat on business trips he opened
his first stand just in time for the
Euro 2012 soccer championship in Poland
I found Anish because no one was selling
German sausages here in Warsaw and
actually Polish people like sausages
grilled sausages especially during the
the summer so I thought to myself that
is a good starting point to open a small
small hole in the wall Roussel imports
his product from just across the border
his snack bar or in this in German
offers six varieties of sausage meals
and the top seller curry Wurst a true
Berlin delicacy I had several meetings
with various embassies in Germany and
Germany and I just watched how they are
being prepared and how they are served
with hot curry sauce and some you know
little things that are important for
German people and that's the way it goes
just like you know in Berlin about a
million and a half tons of sausage are
produced in Germany annually about a
fifth of that total gets exported to
London for instance the British capital
boasts several sausage stands one of the
best known is Herman's a German since
opening three years ago it's made a name
for itself as the worst place to go
the owners are Germans Florian fry and
acidophilic Oishi they get their sausage
straight from the Black Forest from
their neighborhood butcher they started
out with just a catering mobile and then
expanded to two restaurants yet we never
expected I'm that's a bad matter
we started out really small and went our
way and of course we're super happy that
things turned out the way they did and
in another corner of Europe there they
are again at Portugal's southwestern tip
you'll find the last bratwurst and
before America from Spring until fall
Pedro and Wolfgang both sell their
nürnberg style sausage imported by air
cargo the demising gets the most of our
customers are from Spain but of course
we get lots of Germans too they've been
satisfying customers for 17 years now
the Vorst kiosk in Warsaw is branching
out now with some new stands and there
are even mobile worst wagons Criss
crossing Poland so what's the secret
it's simple and it stays good that's the
way it is anyway you slice them smoke
them fry them or steam them come and get
your German sausages before someone else
does